hey what is up everybody it's animac
here for anime uproar and here it is we
finally have the full reveal and
explanation for deku's final Quirk The
Quirk that once belonged to the second
one for all user if used properly and in
combination with deku's other quirks
this new Quirk could be the key to
destroying all for one shigaraki and all
the villains it is absolutely broken and
overpowered and Deco has just ascended
to a whole new plane he may have even
just surpassed Prime all might which is
insane so let's talk about it you guys
know how this works if you enjoy our
vids you want to see more in the future
leave a quick like and comment it only
takes you a second but it helps with
that YouTube algorithm and if you
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification Bell to turn
on all notifications you really have to
go through the trouble of subscribing
hitting the bell and then selecting that
option that says all if you don't do
that you're still going to miss a ton of
our videos even if you are subscribed
it's just how YouTube Works finally this
video will of course contain Boku no
hero manga spoilers so please proceed
with caution you have been warned so as
we signed the last chapter after
arriving on the scene of the battle at
UA Deku got a chance to exchange blows
with all for one slash shigaraki and he
also got a chance to survey the
situation on the battlefield the heroes
who were fighting there are in really
bad shape and Deku felt terrible about
it all for one then taunted Deku which
resulted in Deku getting angry and
almost losing control of his own power
all for one wanted this to happen
because he wanted Deku to make a mistake
that he could exploit but thankfully
Meteo was able to talk Deku down and
Deku regained his composure the chapter
ended with a fierce but fully in
controlled Deku Asking All For One if
shigaraki was still in there somewhere
the latest chapter picks up right where
the last one left off with Deku posing
that same question to Jewel for one all
for one responds by saying that
tomurashigaraki is no more the two
personalities tomurashigaraki and all
for one have now fully merged inside
this body and they became one new being
on top of that the all-for-one
personality was able to take control of
this new being probably because it had a
lot more experience being alive than the
still young tomura that would then
explain why most of what shigaraki is
saying lately seems to be coming
directly from all for one we have all
for one's memories of previous one for
all users we have all for one's mind
games and psychological warfare and all
of that is clearly all for one's doing
and not tomurats but while the
all-for-one personalities seems to be
mostly in control all for one's words
are also misleading because his main
goal here is to demoralize and scare
Deku he wants Deku to believe that
shigaraki's body is already perfect and
Unstoppable and that there is no inner
conflict within him that could
potentially put him at a disadvantage at
some point during the fight as usual
over one is trying to psych out his
opponent but Meteo points out that all
for one is clearly lying the two
personalities have not yet fully fused
within this body because back when Meteo
had mentioned that tomorrow shigaraki
has no friends shigeraki lost it and
began acting like a petulant child there
is no way that all for one would have
willingly acted in this way especially
not during an important battle such as
this one so this proves Beyond a doubt
that all for one does not have full
control at least not yet in fact the
more Meteo and the others pushed
shigaraki over the course of the battle
the more unstable he became which
suggests that shigaraki can still be
defeated there is still hope then the
Vestige of Nana shimura appears and she
also confirms to Deku that tenko shimura
is still in there somewhere she
recognizes that one of the giant fingers
that shigaraki's new form manifested
Bears a striking resemblance to her son
tanko's father and that proves that yes
tanko is still in there and he is still
fighting with the demons from his
childhood all for one sense says that
the heroes may have found his weak spot
so he decides to escalate the fight in
the hopes of taking Deku down before
Deku has a chance to exploit this
weakness all for one's attacks are so
Fierce that they begin to break apart
the very structure of the UA itself
although the fact that the ground is
made up of a bunch of Steel plates that
are not directly connected to each other
means that all for one will have to work
very hard in order to completely break
down the structure of the UA and that of
course was something that nezu had
accounted for when he installed this new
high-tech security system Jack who then
begins his counter-attack by infusing
black whip with fajin in order to create
an epic combo Quirk called black chain
with this move Deku was able to grab
hold of shigaraki and whip him around
the battlefield but he can't hold on to
him for long this move alone will not
bring shiraki down so Deku decides to
bring out his trump card Deku Reveals
His final Quirk The Quirk that once
belonged to the second one for all user
the second user's Vestige appears behind
Deku and advises him to save his Quirk
for last he also says that if they can't
finish all for one slash shigaraki in
the next five minutes then the entire
world is doomed so now is the time to
bring out the big guns now is the time
to whip out the final work this whole
five minutes thing could suggest that
Deku can only use the second user's
Quirk for a limited amount of time so
that means he has to finish the fight
before his time runs out or this could
be referring to how long Deku can keep
using all of his quirks at once in terms
of his general power or the 5 minutes
could be a reference to some other time
limit but after we see just how
overpowered the second user's Quirk is
when combined with one for all I
wouldn't be surprised if using this
takes a huge toll on deku's body and if
there is a firm time limit for how long
he can actually use it I mean if there
isn't a time limit or some sort of
energy limit it is completely broken and
so without further Ado let's talk about
the final Quirk which Deku proceeds to
activate for the first time or at least
for the first time that we as readers
are seeing him do it it is quite likely
that he has already been training with
this Quirk off screen this new quirk
which The Unofficial translation refers
to as transmission allows its user to
shift the speed of anything he touches
so Deku can use it on himself to make
his own movements much faster and that
is the very thing that he does first
with this Quirk transmission also allows
the user to shift the speed of his
opponent after making direct contact
with him and as Deku launches at
shigaraki and punches him into the
abdomen from below this launches
shigaraki rapidly upwards into the air
but even though shigaraki is now flying
upward even faster than before Deku
switches gears to increase his own speed
even further he goes into second gear
and punches shiraki again then into
third gear and punches him again then
into Top Gear and punches him yet again
shigaraki and Deku are now flying in
such an insane speed that Meteo notices
that the sound of deku's punches is
actually delayed this could be
suggesting that deku's current speed is
actually breaking the sound barrier he
may be moving faster than the speed of
sound by the way deku's Top Gear punch
appears to be a direct reference to all
might punching the nomu during the usjr
the position in which Deku finishes the
punch is very similar so this may be a
subtle indicator that Deku has finally
caught up to the power of all might I
mean all might in his prime was an
absolute monster and Deku is still
pretty young but this is supposedly the
Final Act of the series so if there ever
was a time for Deku to catch up to or
even surpass almight this is it on top
of that Deku has access to a whole bunch
of new quirks that all might never had
access to so deku's ability to combine
one for all with all these other quirks
does provide some in-story justification
for Deku potentially reaching the level
of all might at such a young age and of
course since the new shigaraki seems to
be the strongest villain in history
stronger even than all for one at his
prime deck will definitely have to
become the strongest hero in history in
order to defeat him now as these Furious
attacks from Deku are assaulting him
shigaraki Sasha all for one is
struggling to find his bearings and to
figure out what is even happening the
sudden shift in speed and power is just
too much to comprehend and before the
villain can do anything the second user
exclaims that this time things will be
different this time all for one will be
defeated Deku then catches up to the
rapidly moving shigaraki and even
overtakes him using the transmission
quirk's ultimate gear overdrive Deku
then punches down on shigaraki with an
absolutely massive Detroit smash the
power of deku's downward punch smashes
against all of that upward momentum that
chigraki's body had built up after being
punched up so many times and this
creates an absolutely devastating attack
and in fact by using the transmission
quirk in combination with Detroit's
match the power of that Detroit smash
went from a hundred percent to
120 percent so this is even stronger
than the legendary 100 percent one for
all and as this brutal attack connects
with shigaraki's midsection the Vestige
of yoichi the first one for all user
appears and says to his brother that
today is the day that they finally put
an end to all of this their conflict
which has lasted multiple generations
and multiple lifetimes is about to come
to a climactic end and on that momentous
and power system breaking note this
chapter comes to an end wow what a way
to introduce deku's final quirk in
itself this Quirk wasn't something
completely broken like time travel or
teleportation or turning into a Super
Saiyan but when combined with one for
all and all of deku's other quirks this
is an absolutely incredible and
overpowered Quirk I give horikoshi
points on creativity because being able
to change the speed of Everything You
Touch including yourself is going to add
a whole new massive element to deku's
fights from this point onward and I mean
yeah just the fact that Deku can use
different Quirk combos to actually
surpass 100 one for all is in itself a
huge and game-changing development and
honestly all of these recent
developments make me think that my
theory about deku's Quirk Singularity
really could be coming true I mean Deku
is already fusing some of his quirks in
order to create completely new attacks
such as black chain and this new
transmission and one for all Detroit's
Mash combo but imagine if eventually
Deku becomes so powerful that he attains
Quirk Singularity imagine if all seven
of his quirks fuse completely into a
single Quirk that functions completely
differently from the way that any of his
quirks do individually what if deku's
quirks evolve into something totally new
and on precedented something that
changes his body forever and leads him
to a new stage of evolution that Rivals
even that of shigaraki's perfected body
that would escalate the battle between
Deku and shigaraki into something
Monumental something that could
potentially destroy the entire world or
maybe even bend space and time itself do
you guys think that these developments
in the story are leading us towards a
Deku Quirk Singularity and what would
that ultimate overpowered Quirk look
like how would deku's body change in
order to accommodate a quirk like that
let me know down below also let me know
what you thought about this final Quirk
which is so far being referred to as
transmission although that could change
in the official translation what do you
think about the apparent similarities
between this Quirk and Luffy's gears in
one piece I mean they both share the
same concept of like vehicle gears but
deku's Quirk is clearly focused on speed
and actually accelerating and
decelerating while Luffy's years go far
beyond just speed do you believe that
horikoshi made a mistake by making this
final Quirk so similar to Luffy's gear
concept or do you maybe like it let me
know finally what do you think happens
next will Deku now start wrecking
shigaraki slash all for one but then the
villain will find some way of taking out
moroma and getting his quirks back I'd
love to see all your ideas down in the
comments below oh and by the way I don't
really want to talk about this too much
but there was another mha Twitter
controversy this time regarding the
cover page for this week which showed
toru hagakure in her hero costume like
it was literally just her in her
official hero costume the same costume
that she always wears and yet some
people on Twitter freaked out because of
course and I'm sure that these people
complaining about the female character
outfits are definitely not the same
exact people who posed not safe for work
art of the male characters all the time
anyway that's all I have to say about
Twitter nonsense regarding fictional
characters
if you guys enjoyed this video and you
want to see more mha content in the
future leave a quick like and comment it
only takes you a second but it really
helps me out a lot and if you haven't
taken the time to subscribe yet do me a
big favor and make this the video that
you subscribe and hit that notification
Bell to turn on all notifications
subscribing is a completely free way to
directly support this Channel and it
might seem like a small thing to you but
it actually really helps us out a lot on
YouTube you can also hit me up on
Twitter and Instagram at anime Opera big
thank you to all of our anime outpro
patrons for making videos like this one
possible special thank you to trucker
Tim a disciple of Lord twigo himself and
I can't forget all of our the one tier
patrons including Alpha Sigma but they
have the toasted Qi Cory McGowan own
Taylor and Anime s code M finally thank
you to all of our other patrons
including Pro Hero tier patrons the one
and only Gilgamesh on Hell Cruise Alicia
actor Fatboy games kaido might be a duck
alien yeah Sandy and the school bus if
you enjoy our videos and you feel that
they provide value to you consider
supporting us on patreon or by becoming
a channel member as always thank you
guys so much for watching and until next
time see ya Space Cowboys